What is this egg? Seriously, what kind of
ridiculous monstrosity were Roger and his crew
shipping around on their boat,
taking up half of its space?
Here is what I believe the true secret behind
this gigantic egg is and what it may teach us
about the final war of one piece. And why this
little girl we met on Skypea, as we now know,
probably the single most important arc
before the time skip, might be the sky
conterpart to Momonosuke on land in wano and
Shirahoshi under the sea on fishman island.
There has been a ton of speculation
around this throughout the years, but
here are the two main theories that have emerged
over time and that you might be familiar with.
But let me get you up to date: The main, generally
accepted theory, is that the egg on Roger's ship
is the ancient weapon Uranus. This is because
the first time we get to see this mysterious
giant thing on board of the Oro Jackson,
which is the name of Roger's ship,
is when he is encircled by Shiki's armada of
ships. Shiki is a former member of the notorious
Rocks pirates, that was the main antagonist of one
the one piece movie strong world. And even though
this one wasn't canon, Shiki as a character very
much is. This battle between Shiki and Roger takes
place in the special chapter 0 of One Piece,
that was released together with the movie and
unlike the film itself is very much canon,
in other words, a legit part of the story.
In this encounter, where Roger's
situation seems hopeless,
Shiki reveals that he has come for an
apocalyptical weapon that Roger has found
somewhere during his journey, two years before
reaching laugh tale. The only strange thing we
can see on the ship however is the giant
Egg. And like a miracle, a sudden change
of weather brings a storm that helps the Roger
pirates escape this helpless looking situation.
This suggests two things: The storm is
connected to the weapon that Roger has,
and the Weapon is connected to the egg. And as
you well know, an 'apocalyptical weapon' in One
Piece must surely be connected to the so-called
ancient weapons that were created during the void
century. In other words: Egg = apocalyptical
weapon = ancient weapon. And since we already
know about the weapon Poseidon, which is the
mermaid princess Shirahoshi on fishman island
and Pluton seems to be strongly connected to
Momonosuke in Wano, we must conclude that this
egg contains some living being that IS the actual
ancient weapon Uranus. Though, as you will see,
I don't quite agree with that conclusion to
100%. I think it's even better than just that.
Okay, so the egg is connected to Uranus. But what
actually is inside it? Again, people have tried to
narrow it down. Since Poseidon is underwater
and the warship Pluton on the water, Uranus,
which is named after the Greek god of the heavens,
surely must be a connected to the sky. Or, to put
it simply, inside this egg is probably some sort
of creature that can fly. One idea here, is of
course that this could be the egg of a dragon. But
not just any dragon, the last remaining dragon.
Remember, the world of one piece used to have
wild dragons in it hundreds of years ago,
that the government wants to revive so badly, they
put dr. Vegapunk, their super genius on it who
honestly did a pretty decent job I would say with
the dragon we see on Punk Hazard. The celestial
dragons, as their name suggests also seem to have
some connection to this mythical animal, making
the hove of the dragon their actual symbol. There
is of course Luffy's mysterious father, monkey d
dragon, the leader of the revolutionary army and
with Kaido and Momonosuke we have two mythical
devil fruit users with dragon powers, that are not
only incredibly powerful, but also hold a special
meaning. As we now know, Big Mom found this fruit
for Kaido on God Valley, that used to belong to
the celestial dragons. In other words, if this
egg held not just a devil fruit version, but an
actual real Dragon from the past, that would truly
count as a ancient weapon, with the abilities to
change the weather and create destruction,
just like Kaido has shown us throughout Wano.
A really interesting feathered alternative to
this, that I've seen discussed here and there
as well recently, is that the egg might be some
sort of mythical bird. The Rocc comes to mind
for instance, a gignatous and legendary bird from
Middle Eastern mythology, that also made its debut
recently in the story in chapter 1000, as Luffy
shows off his new attack. As I've been told, there
are also a number of legendary birds in Philippine
Mythology, like the Manaul or the concept of the
cosmic bird creator. By the way salamat po to all
Philipons for watching. And then of course, there
is the powerful giant hawk from Nordic mythology,
that sits on top of the world tree Yggdrasil. And
yes, we will of course talk about Elbaf and
Shanks in this video in just a second as well.
Before we move on, a quick shout out to
Elisa Rosales-Solis and Rocky Alonso,
both of whom are subscribed to the channel and
thus have helped me increase my bounty by 100
Berries each, pushing me forward on our quest to
overtake Trebol’s bounty and reach 100M berries.
Okay, so these are basically the most common ideas
about the giant egg that are floating around that
I'm aware of. And they will be important to what
I'm about to tell you next. But I want to take
things even further than just this. I think there
is even more we can conclude about the egg and the
ancient weapon Uranus than just this, and it's
all thanks to the incredible Reddit user Akaore,
who posted a really unique and awesome discussion
about this on my subredit r/WildAnimeTheories,
that basically is just wild one
piece theories at this point,
so make sure to check it out if you're interested.
The core idea here, that I find incredibly
intriguing honestly, is that the ancient weapons
aren't just one thing. Like, just shirahoshi
by herself is NOT Poseidon. Momo by himself is
not Pluton. Instead, he proposes the CCC
theory. Every ancient weapon consists of
3 parts: A Conductor, that controls the
weapon and functions as a sort of key,
a carriage that basically is the
body or the actual weapon itself
and the calvary, powerful beings that can carry
the vehicle and the weapon and move it around.
This is especially based on what we have
seen about Poseidon on fishman island.
Shirahoshi is Poseidon, because she
is able to command the sea kings,
the giant sea monsters that rule over the seas
of the one piece world. Shirahoshi seemingly has
inherited this power through the royal bloodline
from the last mermaid princess that lived
800 years ago, the one JoyBoy made his promise
to. In other words, the key to unlocking the
true power of the ancient weapon Uranus seems
to be genetically encoded into the royal family
of fish-man island. A race that was part of or at
least had really good relations with the ancient
kingdom. By the way, this is pretty incredible.
Like this hints at how technologically advanced
that civilisation actually was and how hard
it fought for a free world in the future.
The third piece of the puzzle here is the
enormous ship Noah that we saw parked in
front of the island. A boat of ridiculous
size, that dates back to the void century and
under no circumstances can be destroyed until it
can fulfil it's purpose. I think many people got
reminded of Pluton when they first saw this
thing. And so I would argue, that the Noah
is actually part of the ancient weapon
Poseidon. You have the conductor, Shirahoshi,
who controls the intelligent sea kings, who
can pull the gigantic boat Noah, something,
we actually saw them do. Like they actively made
sure the Noah is safe. This seems to suggest,
that all 3 together form the ancient weapon
itself. Let's take it even a step further.
You have probably heared about the idea, that at
the end of one piece, the red line and grenadine
will be destroyed to form the legendary all blue.
Well wouldn't Pluton be the perfect tool to get
the fishman to the surface, since their country,
that is located directly under the red line,
would otherwise be buried? And there most likely
would be some other military use for it as well.
So, Shirahoshi and fishman island have given us
the basic idea for how the ancient weapons might
operate as three parts put together. Let's apply
this to the ancient weapon we know the second
most about: Pluton. As we now know, Pluton is
located in Wano. We also have long suspected that
Momonosuke is an ancient weapon as well, who is
able to control the gigantous intelligent elephant
Zunesha, who again dates back to the void century
and had a relationship with joy boy. We also know,
that Pluton has actual physical building plans.
Those are the ones that Tom and ice berg passed
on to Franky, and that Franky then burned
in front of Spandam's face. They were the
entire reason for CP9 being stationed in
water7 for all these years in the first
place. So there is an actual physical ship,
that can be built, that is part of Pluton.
So once again, the 3 C's perfectly match.
We have Momonosuke as the conductor.
A key that has been genetically passed down
from the void century through the bloodline
of the royal Kozuki family, that just
like the fishmen were allied with or
part of the ancient kingdom and joy boy.
Another genetic key. Which, like, let's be real,
engineering the ancient weapons to activate
at a specific Time, only being usable for
specific trusted people is pretty ingenious
by the ancient kingdom, you gotta be honest.
You have Zunesha, who just like the sea
kings can be controlled by Momo, the cavalry,
who can pull a physical warship, the carriage,
for which Franky had the plans and that seems
to be hidden away in or most likely under wano
itself. This would also explain why Momonosuke
said he cant die under any circumstances,
after reading about himself in Oden's journal
and why he will keep Wano's borders closed
for now. He has to wait for the moment,
that he, Shirahoshi and the third person,
that I'll get to in just a second,
will meet and help Luffy slash joy boy to
save the world. After all, both Momonosuke
and Shirahoshi were inspired by luffy, became his
friends and wanted to become as strong as he is.
Which finally brings us aaaallll the way
back to Uranus and the giant egg on Roger's
ship. The gignatous living thing living
inside of it would basically be the sky
counterpart to the sea kings under water
and Zunesha on sea level. In other words,
the cavalry, able to carry the actual ship
part of Uranus. But what about the conductor
and the carriage? Well since it's the
sky version of the 3 ancient weapons,
I think a lot hints towards the sky itself,
where as we know, sky islands exist.
The reason I really like the idea of the nordic
mythology bird that sits on top of the world tree
inside the egg, is that our next goal in the story
is most likely Elbaf. Elbaf not only has a giant
tree, inspired by the tree Yggdrasil itself, but
it also seems to be protected by Shanks, who is
full of Nordic themes himself. Since shanks was
actually part of Rogers crew, he might protect
Elbaf for exactly that purpose. Now I think the
giants of Elbaf were also allied with the ancient
kingdom and joy boy. And there is a real chance,
that the Conductor counterpart to SHirahoshi and
Momonosuke is someone from the royal family of
Elbaf. However, there is a lot more evidence
that point at another ancient race here. The
Shandorans of Skypea. The proud people who lived
in the golden city with its golden bell and the
poneglpyh that talked about Poseidon on fishman
island. Skypea, that as you know from the big
Yuderon theory, might well have been the actual
location of the ancient kingdom itself. But then,
what does Elbaf have to do with the sky islands?
Well, as you might remember, the straw hats took
the 'unofficial' route to the sky islands using
the knock up stream. However there is also an
official way to reach Skypea. And I'm neither the
first nor the only person who strongly believes
that the giant tree on Elbaf might actually be
just that entrance, that might have the giant
bird from Roger's egg sitting and waiting on top.
Which would then leave us with two more questions:
Who is the conductor? And what is the ship?
Well, what if I told you, that we have seen
both already. Don't you also find, that Enel's
arc Maxim is a bit of a curiosity. Enel is not
exactly the brightest lamp in the socket and so
it's really curious that he managed to come up
with the concept of the arc maxima. Only that we
know that Enel did not build this ship himself,
but forced God's men, the people of skypea
sworn to the person who holds the title of 'God'
to build the ship for him. Isn't it much
more likely that instead of Enel being a
secret engineering genius, he found the plans
for the arc maxim in god's room, similarly to
how there are plans to the pluton. Remember this
is a ship that is capable of traveling space.
With Luffy slash joy boy being the sun god
Nika, who by the way was first forshadowd
exactly here on Skypea, wouldn't it
make sense, that the title of God
originally belonged to Joy Boy? The original
creator of the 3 ancient weapons? In other words,
isn't it much more likely that the arc maxim
is the ship part of the ancient weapon Uranus,
which's plans got passed down among
the sky people for generations.
Which only leaves us with the person to control
the giant bird to carry the arc and complete the
ancient weapon. And that very person is
most likely this little girl here: Aisa.
In case you forgot, this little girl
allegedly was born with increadibly
overpowered observation haki, being able to
hear the entirety of skypea. But does that
really make sense? A kid who
is born with overpowered haki?
Doesn't this remind you much more of Momonosuke
hearing Zuneshia's voice for the first time? Isn't
it much more reasonable to assume that this little
girl has the voices of all things? Like Luffy,
like Momo and like Shirahoshi? And just like
Momo and the mermaid princess, Aisa was saved and
inspired by Luffy. It's an arc and relationship
with Luffy, that's exclusive to those 3 kids.
And while we don't who Aisa's parents were,
we DO in fact know that the Shandorans have
a royal line, like the Kozuki or the royal family
of the fishmen, that could carry the key gene,
necessary for awakening the conductor.
Which gives us people from the sea,
the land and the sky, a creature from the
sea the land and the sky as well as a ship
for each of them. And since we're most likely
going to elbaf and the top of Yggdrasil next,
it would be very easy for Oda to
bring Aisa back into the story.
And speaking of Elbaf, if you want to know
what else might happen on the island and
what has been foreshadowed, you really
shouldn't miss out on this video right here.
Okay, so these are basically the most common
ideas about the giant egg that are floating
around that I'm aware of. And they will
be important to what I'm about to tell
you next. But I want to take things even
further than just this. I think there is
even more we can conclude about the egg and
the ancient weapon Uranus than just this,
and it's all thanks to the incredible Reddit
user Akaore, who posted a really unique and
awesome discussion about this on my subredit
r/WildAnimeTheories, that basically is just
wild one piece theories at this point, so make
sure to check it out if you're interested.
The core idea here, that I find incredibly
intriguing honestly, is that the ancient
weapons aren't just one thing. Like, just
shirahoshi by herself is NOT Poseidon. Momo
by himself is not Pluton. Instead, he proposes
the CCC theory. Every ancient weapon consists of
3 parts: A Conductor, that controls the
weapon and functions as a sort of key,
a carriage that basically is the body or
the actual weapon itself and the calvary,
powerful beings that can carry the
vehicle and the weapon and move it around.
This is especially based on what we have seen
about Poseidon on fishman island. Shirahoshi
is Poseidon, because she is able to command
the sea kings, the giant sea monsters that
rule over the seas of the one piece world.
Shirahoshi seemingly has inherited this power
through the royal bloodline from the last
mermaid princess that lived 800 years ago,
the one JoyBoy made his promise to. In other
words, the key to unlocking the true power
of the ancient weapon Uranus seems to be
genetically encoded into the royal family
of fish-man island. A race that was part of or at
least had really good relations with the ancient
kingdom. By the way, this is pretty incredible.
Like this hints at how technologically advanced
that civilisation actually was and how hard
it fought for a free world in the future.
The third piece of the puzzle here is the
enormous ship Noah that we saw parked in
front of the island. A boat of ridiculous size,
that dates back to the void century and under
no circumstances can be destroyed until it
can fulfil it's purpose. I think many people
got reminded of Pluton when they first saw
this thing. And so I would argue, that the
Noah is actually part of the ancient weapon
Poseidon. You have the conductor, Shirahoshi,
who controls the intelligent sea kings, who
can pull the gigantic boat Noah, something,
we actually saw them do. Like they actively made
sure the Noah is safe. This seems to suggest,
that all 3 together form the ancient weapon
itself. Let's take it even a step further.
You have probably heared about the idea, that at
the end of one piece, the red line and grenadine
will be destroyed to form the legendary all blue.
Well wouldn't Pluton be the perfect tool to get
the fishman to the surface, since their country,
that is located directly under the red line,
would otherwise be buried? And there most likely
would be some other military use for it as well.
So, Shirahoshi and fishman island have given us
the basic idea for how the ancient weapons might
operate as three parts put together. Let's apply
this to the ancient weapon we know the second
most about: Pluton. As we now know, Pluton is
located in Wano. We also have long suspected that
Momonosuke is an ancient weapon as well, who is
able to control the gigantous intelligent elephant
Zunesha, who again dates back to the void century
and had a relationship with joy boy. We also know,
that Pluton has actual physical building
plans. Those are the ones that Tom and ice
berg passed on to Franky, and that Franky then
burned in front of Spandam's face. They were
the entire reason for CP9 being stationed
in water7 for all these years in the first
place. So there is an actual physical ship,
that can be built, that is part of Pluton.
So once again, the 3 C's perfectly match.
We have Momonosuke as the conductor. A key
that has been genetically passed down from
the void century through the bloodline of
the royal Kozuki family, that just like
the fishmen were allied with or part of
the ancient kingdom and joy boy. Another
genetic key. Which, like, let's be real,
engineering the ancient weapons to activate
at a specific Time, only being usable for
specific trusted people is pretty ingenious
by the ancient kingdom, you gotta be honest.
You have Zunesha, who just like the sea
kings can be controlled by Momo, the cavalry,
who can pull a physical warship, the carriage,
for which Franky had the plans and that seems
to be hidden away in or most likely under wano
itself. This would also explain why Momonosuke
said he cant die under any circumstances,
after reading about himself in Oden's journal
and why he will keep Wano's borders closed for
now. He has to wait for the moment, that he,
Shirahoshi and the third person,
that I'll get to in just a second,
will meet and help Luffy slash joy boy to
save the world. After all, both Momonosuke
and Shirahoshi were inspired by luffy, became his
friends and wanted to become as strong as he is.
Which finally brings us aaaallll the way
back to Uranus and the giant egg on Roger's
ship. The gignatous living thing living
inside of it would basically be the sky
counterpart to the sea kings under water
and Zunesha on sea level. In other words,
the cavalry, able to carry the actual ship
part of Uranus. But what about the conductor
and the carriage? Well since it's the
sky version of the 3 ancient weapons,
I think a lot hints towards the sky itself,
where as we know, sky islands exist.
The reason I really like the idea of the nordic
mythology bird that sits on top of the world tree
inside the egg, is that our next goal in the story
is most likely Elbaf. Elbaf not only has a giant
tree, inspired by the tree Yggdrasil itself,
but it also seems to be protected by Shanks,
who is full of Nordic themes himself. Since shanks
was actually part of Rogers crew, he might protect
Elbaf for exactly that purpose. Now I think the
giants of Elbaf were also allied with the ancient
kingdom and joy boy. And there is a real chance,
that the Conductor counterpart to SHirahoshi and
Momonosuke is someone from the royal family of
Elbaf. However, there is a lot more evidence
that point at another ancient race here. The
Shandorans of Skypea. The proud people who lived
in the golden city with its golden bell and the
poneglpyh that talked about Poseidon on fishman
island. Skypea, that as you know from the big
Yuderon theory, might well have been the actual
location of the ancient kingdom itself. But then,
what does Elbaf have to do with the sky islands?
Well, as you might remember, the straw hats took
the 'unofficial' route to the sky islands using
the knock up stream. However there is also an
official way to reach Skypea. And I'm neither the
first nor the only person who strongly believes
that the giant tree on Elbaf might actually be
just that entrance, that might have the giant
bird from Roger's egg sitting and waiting on top.
Which would then leave us with two more questions:
Who is the conductor? And what is the ship? Well,
what if I told you, that we have seen
both already. Don't you also find,
that Enel's arc Maxim is a bit of a curiosity.
Enel is not exactly the brightest lamp in the
socket and so it's really curious that he
managed to come up with the concept of the
arc maxima. Only that we know that Enel did not
build this ship himself, but forced God's men,
the people of skypea sworn to the person who
holds the title of 'God' to build the ship for
him. Isn't it much more likely that instead
of Enel being a secret engineering genius,
he found the plans for the arc maxim in
god's room, similarly to how there are
plans to the pluton. Remember this is a
ship that is capable of traveling space.
With Luffy slash joy boy being the sun god
Nika, who by the way was first forshadowd
exactly here on Skypea, wouldn't it make
sense, that the title of God originally
belonged to Joy Boy? The original creator
of the 3 ancient weapons? In other words,
isn't it much more likely that the arc maxim
is the ship part of the ancient weapon Uranus,
which's plans got passed down among
the sky people for generations.
Which only leaves us with the person to control
the giant bird to carry the arc and complete the
ancient weapon. And that very person is
most likely this little girl here: Aisa.
In case you forgot, this little girl
allegedly was born with increadibly
overpowered observation haki, being able to
hear the entirety of skypea. But does that
really make sense? A kid who is born with
overpowered haki? Doesn't this remind you
much more of Momonosuke hearing Zuneshia's
voice for the first time? Isn't it much more
reasonable to assume that this little girl
has the voices of all things? Like Luffy,
like Momo and like Shirahoshi? And just like
Momo and the mermaid princess, Aisa was saved and
inspired by Luffy. It's an arc and relationship
with Luffy, that's exclusive to those 3 kids.
And while we don't who Aisa's parents were,
we DO in fact know that the Shandorans have a
royal line, like the Kozuki or the royal family
of the fishmen, that could carry the key gene,
necessary for awakening the conductor.
Which gives us people from the sea,
the land and the sky, a creature from the
sea the land and the sky as well as a ship
for each of them. And since we're most likely
going to elbaf and the top of Yggdrasil next,
it would be very easy for Oda to
bring Aisa back into the story.
And speaking of Elbaf, if you want to
know what else might happen on the island
and what has been foreshadowed, you really
shouldn't miss out on this video right here.